JENS STOLTENBERG REITERATED
SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE THIS
MORNING.
>> NATO WILL CONTINUE TO STAND
WITH UKRAINE FOR AS LONG AS IT
TAKES.
WE WILL NOT BACK DOWN.
>> AND THE SECRETARY GENERAL
JOINS US NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT HUNGARY,
FIRST OFF, SAYING IT WILL RAD
FIE FINLAND AND SWEDEN'S BID
NEXT YEAR.
AS YOU KNOW, TURKEY AND HUNGARY
ARE THE ONLY ALLIANCE WHO HAVE
NOT CLEARED THIS.
WHAT'S THE RISK WITH DELAYING IT
UNTIL EARLY NEXT YEAR?
>> I'M CONFIDENT THAT BOTH
HUNGARY AND TURKEY WILL RATIFY
THE PROTOCOLS FOR FINLAND AND
SWEDEN.
I CANNOT TELL YOU EXACTLY WHEN.
BUT WE ALL HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
ALL ALLIES MADE A HISTORIC
DECISION IN JUNE THIS YEAR TO
INVITE SWEDEN AND FINLAND TO
BECOME MEMBERS OF THE ALLIANCE.
AND ALL ALLIES SIGNED THE
PROTOCOLS.
SO FAR, 28 OUT OF 30 MEMBERS
HAVE RATIFIED THESE PROTOCOLS IN
THE NATIONAL PARLIAMENT.
SO THIS IS ONE OF THE FASTEST
EVER ACCESSION PROCESSES IN
NATO'S HISTORY.
AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT ALSO, THE
TWO REMAINING PARLIAMENTS WILL
RATIFY SO WE ENSURE FINLAND AND
SWEDEN BECOMES FULL MEMBERS.
>> IS THERE A RISK IF THEY WAIT
TO RATIFY IT UNTIL NEXT YEAR?
>> WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
FINLAND AND SWEDEN AND SWEDEN
ARE IN A DIFFERENT PLACE NOW
THAN WHEN THEY APPLIED.
AFTER THEY APPLIED IN MAY, FIRST
OF ALL THEY ARE NOW
PARTICIPATING AS WHAT WE CALL
INVITEES IN NATO'S MILITARY AND
CIVILIAN ACTIVITIES COOPERATION.
NATO HAS INCREASED THE MILITARY
PRESENCE IN THE REGION, IN THE
BALTIC REGION.
AND SEVERAL ALLIES, INCLUDING
THE UNITED STATES, HAVE ISSUED
SECURITY ISSUES TO FINLAND AND
SWEDEN SO IT'S INCONCEIVABLE
THAT IF FINLAND AND SWEDEN OR
ATTACKED OR PUT UNDER SOME KIND
OF PRESSURE THAT NATO WOULD NOT
REACT.
SO WE'VE COME A LONG WAY ALREADY
AND AGAIN, THIS PROCESS HAS SO
FAR GONE FASTER OR QUICKER THAN
MOST OTHER PROCESSES OF THIS
LINES.
>> GERMANY OFFERED POLAND THE
PATRIOT AIR DEFENSE SYSTEMS
AFTER THE MISSILE WAS FIRED AND
LANDED IN POLAND.
BUT POLISH OFFICIALS ARE SAYING
THEY WANT GERMANY TO SEND IT TO
UKRAINE INSTEAD.
GERMANY'S DEFENSE MINISTER SAID
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WOULD HAVE
TO BE AGREED TO BY NATO.
IS THIS SOMETHING YOU THINK NATO
WOULD AGREE TO?
>> YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
NATO ALLIES HAVE ALREADY
PROVIDED SIGNIFICANT AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS TO UKRAINE AND ALSO
INCREASED OUR PRESENCE IN
EASTERN PART OF THE ALLIANCE,
INCLUDING IN POLAND.
AND I WELCOME THE GERMAN OFFER
TO STRENGTHEN AIR DEFENSES IN
POLAND.
BECAUSE THAT WILL FIT INTO WHAT
WE'VE ALREADY DONE, ESPECIALLY
AFTER THE INVASION IN FEBRUARY.
WE HAVE MORE TROOPS ON THE
GROUND, MORE AIR AND NAVAL
ASSETS AND SIGNIFICANT PART
ABOUT THIS ALSO, DIFFERENT TYPES
OF AIR DEFENSE SYSTEMS TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE THERE TO PROTECT AND
DEFEND EVERY INCH OF NATO
TERRITORY.
BY DOING SO WE'RE PREVENTING
ESCALATION OF THE CONFLICT
BEYOND UKRAINE.
JUST THIS WEEK I WAS IN SPAIN.
SPAIN ANNOUNCED THEY WILL
PROVIDE MORE BATTERIES, NATO
ALLIES HAVE PROVIDED BATTERIES
TO ADVANCE NATO AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS.
AT THE END IT WILL BE A NATIONAL
DECISION ON THE SPECIFIC
CAPABILITIES, BUT I CONTINUE TO
CALL ON ALLIES TO STEP UP AND
PROVIDE EVEN MORE AIR DEFENSES
ALSO FOR UKRAINE.
>> IS IT MORE EFFECTIVE FOR
THESE DEFENSE SYSTEMS TO GO TO
POLAND AND BE THERE CLOSE TO THE
UKRAINIAN BORDER OR SHOULD THEY
GO STRAIGHT TO UKRAINE, IN YOUR
VIEW?
>> WE NEED BOTH.
WE NEED BOTH INCREASED AIR
DEFENSE OF OUR NATO ALLIES IN
THE EAST, THE BALTIC COUNTRIES,
POLAND, ROMANIA, BUT ALSO WE
NEED MORE AIR DEFENSE IN
UKRAINE.
THAT'S ONLY BVIOUS.
WE SEE THE HORRENDOUS, HORRIFIC
ATTACKS EVERY DAY AGAINST
CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE, AGAINST
CITIES IN UKRAINE, AND
THEREFORE, WE NEED TO HELP
UKRAINE BE ABLE TO SHOOT DOWN
THOSE INCOMING RUSSIAN MISSILES
AND DRONES.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
DOING.
BUT WE SHOULD FURTHER STEP UP
AND THAT'S MY CALL TO NATO
ALLIES.
>> YOU'VE OBVIOUSLY SEEN THE
LATEST ATTACKS FROM RUSSIA
CONTINUING TO GO AFTER ESSENTIAL
SERVICES TO UKRAINE.
WE WERE TALKING EARLIER THEY
WERE HAVING TO PERFORM HEART
SURGERY BASICALLY BY FLASHLIGHT
IN SOME SITUATIONS.
DO YOU BELIEVE THIS IS A RUSSIAN
CAMPAIGN OF TERROR ON UKRAINIAN
CIVILIANS?
>> WHAT WE SEE NOW IS THAT
PRESIDENT PUTIN IS TRYING TO
WEAPONIZE WINTER.
AND BY DELIBERATE ATTACKS ON
CITIES ON CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE, HE TRIES TO
DEPRIVE THE UKRAINIANS OF GAS,
HEATING, WATER.
AND THIS JUST DEMONSTRATES ONCE
AGAIN THE BRUTALITY OF THIS WAR,
AND IMPORTANCE OF PRESIDENT
PUTIN, RUSSIA, ENDING THIS WAR.
THE BEST WAY WE CAN ADDRESS THE
HORRIFIC SCENES WE SEE FROM
UKRAINE IS TO SUPPORT UKRAINE.
I WOULD LIKE TO COMMEND,
ESPECIALLY UNITED STATES, FOR
PROVIDING UNPRECEDENTED SUPPORT
TO UKRAINE, MILITARY SUPPORT,
AND ALSO HELP THEM TO REPAIR THE
ENERGY GRID, THE GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE, IN ADDITION TO
THE AIR DEFENSE SYSTEMS WE ARE
PROVIDING.
AND WE DO THAT BECAUSE WE -- WE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH
UKRAINE.
BUT ALSO IT IS BECAUSE OUR OWN
SECURITY INTEREST TO ENSURE THAT
PRESIDENT PUTIN DOES NOT WIN IN
UKRAINE.
>> SPEAKING OF WHAT THE END OF
THIS COULD LOOK LIKE, DO YOU
AGREE WITH THE SENTIMENT YOU'VE
HEARD FROM THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF, MARK
MILLEY SAYING THE IDEA IT WOULD
BE POSSIBLE FOR UKRAINE TO
COMPLETELY PUSH RUSSIA OUT, IT
WOULD BE A VERY DIFFICULT TASK
FOR THE UKRAINIANS?
>> THE UKRAINIANS ARE, BY FAR,
PAYING THE HIGHEST PRICE FOR
THIS WAR.
WHAT WE DO IS MEASURED IN MONEY,
WHAT THEY DO IS MEASURED IN
BLOOD, LOST LIVES EVERY DAY.
SO IT HAS TO BE UP TO UKRAINE TO
DECIDE.
WE NEED TO REMEMBER WHAT THIS
IS.
THIS IS A WAR OF AGGRESSION BY
RUSSIA AGAINST AN INDEPENDENT
SOVEREIGN DEMOCRATIC NATION IN
EUROPE WITH NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED BORDERS.
NATO AND NATO ALLIES ARE NOT
PARTY TO THE CONFLICT BUT WE
HELP UKRAINE TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
THE RIGHT TO SELF-DEFENSE IS
ENSHRINED IN THE U.N.
CHARLOTCHARTER.
MORE WARS END AT THE NEGOTIATING
TABLE BUT AROUND THE NEGOTIATING
TABLE IS DEPENDENT ON THE
STRENGTH ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
IF WE WANT UKRAINE TO PREVAIL AS
A SOVEREIGN INDEPENDENT STATE WE
MUST PROVIDE MILITARY SUPPORT TO
UKRAINE SO WHEN THERE WILL
LIKELY BE NOEGOTIATIONS AT SOME
TIME WE CAN PRESENT RESULTS THAT
ENSURE THEY CONTINUE AS A STATE
OF SOVEREIGNTY IN EUROPE.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING.